Sau giờ, mất cuộc tức dựng dựng API được Mỹ cấp bằng sáng xế bởi dù API video.
Nó tìvút tức tục gây chui khi chính thức giảm bắt từ vệ lụ tìvút Amerika, Nó Gisen Sen.
Còn tức API, nên tảng dựng dựng được quyền bố chợ để kháng khai,
tư hoa tốt cho mấy, vô được cấp bằng sáng xế từ Mỹ,
chờ thành cột mốt khẳng định năng lực nghi cứu và phát phát sìng của Nó tìvút trên tỷ trường tạng cầu.
Nhưng gì này, Nó tìvút của bố hợp tắc chính là cùng lưỡi tắc tại hoa ki để phát triển Nó tìvút Amerika, Nó Gisen Sen.
Tư hiệu mới được xây dựng trên nền tảng cầu tức API kết hợp cùng hoa b sin dữ hiện đại của Mỹ,
sự giúp đặc ai thêm đàn bỏ ai thần chung cùng nhiều giữ chất tiếp ước,
hương đến các sẵn sở phẩm dữ giữ cộp cấp sáng trong người tư dụng hiện đại.
Sự kiến có sự tham sự của ông Hoang Minh, tư trường bộ khá công nghệ, ông buổi tá hoang buồn,
giảm đắp sự công phương thành phố xin mi.
Bà phảo khai phong lần, giảm đắp sự át đoàn thức phẩm kênh của xin mi, ông Gisen Sen.
Phó giảm đắp sự ngoại vụ tên phố xin mi.
Bà Minh sẽ ước báo, tổng lãi sự quan phát ki, ông Gren, Mila,
Phó chủ tịch yêu hành nghiệp hội sữ khai phó nhá,
Sien A Dì cũng mang lãnh gạo nguy tí phút và cơ lối táp chính lượng trong vòng ngoài nước.
Đây được xem là mình chúng cho khách phỏ trở thành giang nghiệp phóa vinh giữ mạng tâm phó phút tế,
đồng thời gian thật phóa sức mạng in tư trận dưng giữ tế tế của thế giới đến hần hơn với các gia đình.